pourvu que ça dure vous est présenté par
écho DDS éco-organismes qui agit pour
une économie respectueuse de
l'environnement
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les
correspondances sur Public Sénat
aujourd'hui focus sur le transport qui
représente albisol près d'un tiers des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre il est
donc urgent d'agir pour la planète pour
notre santé mais aussi pour notre
porte-monnaie car avec la flambée des
prix des carburants conduire n'a jamais
coûté aussi cher heureusement des modes
de transport alternatifs moins polluants
existent passage en revue de ces
nouvelles mobilités vertes dans quelques
instants avec le syndicat mobiliance et
puis les opérateurs sont aussi sur le
pont des carbonations de la flotte
solution pour sortir du tout auto dans
les îles et en périphérie Thierry Mallet
le patron de Transdev nous parlera de sa
stratégie face à l'urgence climatique
enfin bus à hydrogène ou capsule
autonome on vous parlera de ces
technologies qui révolutionnent notre
manière de se déplacer en ville mais
d'abord tout ce qu'il faut savoir sur
les transports et leur impact en moins
d'une minute c'est parti le transport un
secteur très polluant oui en France il
représente 31% des émissions de gaz à en
cause le transport routier responsable
de la quasi-totalité avec 94% de ses
émissions alors que l'aérien c'est 4,4%
et le ferroviaire
0,4%. et c'est la voiture qui pollue le
plus avec 54 % des émissions de CO2
contre 24% pour les poids lourds et 20%
pour les véhicules utilitaires légers et
quels sont les dégâts pour notre santé
l'OMS a classé cette pollution comme
cancérigène pour l'homme et pour cause
en plus de produire des gaz toxiques les
véhicules émettent des particules fines
20 fois plus petites que le diamètre
d'un cheveu
en suspension dans l'air elles peuvent
facilement pénétrer dans l'organisme et
provoquer des pathologies respiratoires
cardiovasculaires ou neurologiques en
France elle réduisent l'espérance de vie
de 8,2 mois et sont à l'origine de 100
000 décès prématurés par an et quid de
la pollution sonore 10 millions de
Français sont exposés quotidiennement à
des niveaux supérieurs à 70 décibels
alors que le seuil de confort est fixé à
55 décibels provoquant troubles du
sommeil acouphènes migraines ou encore
dépression
[Musique]
depuis le covid on assiste à une
mutation des transports avec des
attentes qui ont évolué de la part des
usagers Dorothée des re-bonjour bonjour
merci d'être là vous êtes la directrice
des affaires publiques du syndicat
mobiliance et vous avez donc une vision
et c'est très intéressant globale des
nouvelles mobilités vous avez publié
récemment un guide des nouvelles
mobilités donc c'est un peu une photo de
ce qui se de ce qui se fait aujourd'hui
déjà premier point on a l'impression que
c'est une impression je ne sais pas vous
me direz que la crise sanitaire a
provoqué une prise de conscience mais
couplée la crise climatique et à celle
du port d'achat on a ce sentiment que
tout converge aujourd'hui vers ce même
constat il faut trouver des alternatives
plus propres et surtout plus économiques
à quoi à la bagnole à la voiture c'est
ça alors c'est complexe en fait c'est
vrai que on a on a subi plusieurs crises
une crise covid qui a été extrêmement je
pense qu'il y a modifié profondément la
conscience de nos modes de mobilité on a
assisté aussi pendant ces trois quatre
dernières années un essor réglementaire
pour répondre au défi climatique
à la fois à Bruxelles et à Paris au
niveau national donc en fait ça provoque
je dirais que la réglementation quelque
part pousse des nouvelles mobilités les
encouragent donc on voit vraiment
effectivement qu'il y a un changement de
paradigme clairement changement des
usages de prise de conscience poussée
par cette réglementation et c'est vrai
une prise de conscience que la voiture
individuelle ce n'est pas la seule
réponse notamment dans les zones des
métropoles par exemple justement du tout
voiture il y a cette interdiction des
ventes de voitures neuves on connaît la
date en 2035 et il y a de la l'homme la
loi d'orientation des mobilités et ce
qu'elle a commencé ou pas à produire ses
effets est-ce que les gens commencent
quand ils le peuvent un petit peu
délaisser leur voiture alors oui et ça
pour plusieurs raisons déjà on a la mise
en place
c'est pas la marche il y a quelque chose
une prise de conscience notamment par
rapport à la mise en place des zona
faibles émissions Les ZFE il y a 11
aides et ceux qui ont été mises en place
par la loi l'homme donc la loi
d'orientation des mobilités et on est
passé à 43 avec la loi climat et
résilience toutes les villes de plus de
150 000 habitants donc aujourd'hui vous
avez quand même une interdiction
potentielle d'ici 2025 des critères 1 5
à critères 3 des véhicules qui ne
pourront plus rouler dans ces métropoles
donc en fait quelque part c'est un effet
d'entraînement pour les usagers qui vont
avoir une problématique de pouvoir
d'achat ne pourront pas forcément
renouveler leur véhicule donc ça c'est
aujourd'hui on sait que ces ZFE ça va
quand même exclure à peu près 38% du
parc automobile et donc ces usagers ils
sont à la recherche de nouveaux modes de
mobilité de nouvelles solutions parmi
ces nouvelles solutions de mobilité
partagée il y a le covoiturage est-ce
que c'est vraiment en train de se
démocratiser et de décoller on a envie
de dire oui quand on écoute le
gouvernement qui nous dit que ça
cartonne chiffre à l'appui évidemment de
covoiturage alors c'est vrai qu'il y a
eu un vrai essor du covoiturage qui est
une vraie réponse à la décarbonation des
transports ça a beaucoup progressé alors
c'est vrai que la loi l'homme a mis en
place une boîte à outils avec les AOM
les autorités organisatrices des
mobilités qui peuvent effectivement
s'emparer du covoiturage et le
développer dans les territoires
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'effectivement il y a de plus en plus
d'opérateurs à la fois de covoiturage
longue distance et courte distance et le
gouvernement a aussi mis en place des
dispositifs incitatifs du type forfait
mobilité durable qui permet d'encourager
le covoiturage pour les trajets domicile
travail après il y a aussi le free
flotting pour les trottinettes ou le
vélo vers vélo soit en passant vélo
électrique qui est un des grands
gagnants des nouvelles mobilités
est-ce que ça fonctionne bien
aujourd'hui parce que on a vu que les
Parisiens ont dit non aux trottinette en
libre-service la Paris n'est pas le
reste de la France déjà il faut minorer
le vote de Paris puisque en réalité
c'est 4% des Parisiens qui ont voté donc
ça fait très peu par rapport à la
réalité des usagers et par ailleurs
quand on regarde la France entière
certes Paris a voté non mais donc encore
une fois il faut regarder quand même le
nombre d'électeurs qui ont effectivement
voté et le reste des villes de en région
notamment Lyon Bordeaux on gardait la
trottinette qui est un véritable mode
qui répond à des problématiques de
pouvoir d'achat parce que c'est souvent
des jeunes publics ou des publics plus
modestes ça ne coûte pas très cher de se
déplacer en trottinette c'est un mode
doux et c'est vrai qu'on peut un peu
s'étonner qui se mode et été abandonné à
Paris juste avant les Jeux Olympiques
bon c'est nous on trouve que le
calendrier était pas forcément très
propice par ailleurs les acteurs ont
fait beaucoup ont pris beaucoup
d'engagements ils ont signé une charte
avec le ministre des Transports Clément
Beaune qui demande par exemple que la
trottinette ne soit utilisée pour que
pour les usagers de plus de 14 ans qui
demandent des aménagements et des
infrastructures dans la ville qui soient
propices aux fruits flotting des
trottinettes
en tout cas ça n'est pas interdit et
nous ce qu'on propose c'est surtout de
bien réguler et une vraie concertation
entre les opérateurs et les
collectivités qui est la clé d'une bonne
régulation des trottinettes l'autre
grosse tendance aujourd'hui c'est
l'Inter modalité en gros les usagers
vont piocher plusieurs modes de
transport pour se déplacer un petit peu
de vélo un petit peu de métro un peu de
marche un peu d'autopartage à vivre au
quotidien c'est pas trop galère quand
même au contraire aujourd'hui
l'intermodalité ça permet de répondre à
la fameuse prématique des zones blanches
parce qu'on n'a pas des transports
publics partout et on pense aux villes
et après effectivement il reste de la
France et il faut pas qu'il y ait une
fracture territoriale nous avec
l'ensemble de nos opérateurs de mobilité
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il existe encore
des zones blanches et que il faut
vraiment proposer des outils qui
permettent d'avoir un peu une mobilité
sans couture c'est à dire une mobilité
où vous pouvez prendre un vélo puis un
transport public puis après faire du
covoiturage etc c'est à dire c'est cette
mobilité sans couture et on a beaucoup
de discussions avec le Gouvernement sur
ce sujet notamment sur ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure le forfait
mobilité durable c'est un bon outil
incitatif pour développer des modes de
mobilité douce sur et domicile travail
on est aussi en discussion sur des
dispositifs comme le budget mobilité
unique qui permet en fait de fusionner
le versement transport et tout ce qui
est dispositif incitatif pour les
nouvelles mobilités parce que c'est
surtout aussi financier il faut que ça
soit bien harmonisé pour que ce soit
bien compréhensible par les usagers
un peu pardon mais je sais que le
gouvernement travaille aussi pour aller
plus loin dans cette inter modalité et
veut mettre en place d'ici deux ans le
Titre unique de transport pour toutes
les mobilités c'est pas la même chose
alors le titre de transport unique
effectivement
on dit que c'est pas simple à mettre en
place mais sauf que c'est que pour les
transports publics alors que le budget
mobilité unique ce serait vraiment un
budget qui serait donné par l'employeur
à la fois pour le transport public et
les nouvelles mobilités type covoiturage
autopartage vélo électrique donc ça
permet quand même de répondre à une
problématique où vous pouvez avoir tout
mode de transport transport public et
nouvelle mobilité après on a beaucoup
parlé des villes bien desservies avec
beaucoup d'offres de transport encore
une fois est-ce qu'on appelle ça les
zones blanches en tout cas les zones
périurbaines rural là-bas il y a pardon
il y a pas d'offre les gens n'ont pas le
choix autre que de prendre leur voiture
comment on aide ces territoires alors
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut voir dans
l'état des lieux c'est déjà qu'il y a
toujours 70% des Français qui utilisent
leur voiture pour le trajet
domicile-travail et 76% qui utilisent
leur voiture pour des trajets entre 100
et 800 km donc en fait la voiture elle
reste quand même le mode incontournable
et notamment dans les territoires donc
il faut aider vraiment en fait les
Français qui vivent en territoire
à pouvoir quand même continuer à je
dirais à pouvoir utiliser leur voiture
mais aussi à développer dans ces
territoires et ça on est encore un petit
peu au démarrage des nouveaux modes de
mobilité des modes de mobilité innovants
avec aussi les AOM en les financement
qui tient la route par exemple pour le
jeu de mots pour ces territoires tout à
fait le covoiturage ça peut être une
réponse dans les territoires mais il
faut avoir les infrastructures et
aujourd'hui en France on est encore un
peu de retard sur tout ce qui est multi
mod
alors des hub qui vous permettent en
fait d'utiliser d'arriver avec votre
voiture et d'utiliser ensuite du
covoiturage ou en tout cas d'avoir cette
mobilité en périphérie des villes qui
vous permettent de passer d'un mode de
mobilité de transport à un autre c'est
beaucoup développé dans d'autres pays
européens aujourd'hui on le voit par
exemple au Pays-Bas ou dans certains
pays au Royaume-Uni également ils ont
cette culture par exemple bon à Londres
vous avez des parkings en zone
périurbaine à Paris on n'a pas fait ce
choix là aujourd'hui et on devra
sûrement y venir notamment avec ces
zones affaiblissions
publiques du syndicat mobiliance merci
alors on l'a dit les innovations ne
manquent pas pour sortir du tout-voiture
et proposer des modes de transport
efficace innovant et neutres en émission
de CO2 certaines preuves d'autres
devraient équiper nos villes du futur
manuel legre en France le transport
c'est 31% des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050 le secteur doit se
réinventer et le transport en commun
compte montrer l'exemple
bonne soirée comme à Versailles en
région parisienne une ligne de bus est
en mutation après le bus diesel hybride
et électrique c'est au tour du bus à
hydrogène d'arpenter les 12 km de la
ligne 264 entre Jouy-en-Josas et
Versailles emprunté chaque jour par plus
de 1000 voyageurs alors là moi je ne
rejette que de la vapeur d'eau tout ce
qui est polluant tout ce qui irrite les
gens tout ce qui tout ce qui pollue on
l'a pas nous on transporte des gens avec
de l'eau c'est quand même impressionnant
quoi des gouttelettes d'eau rejetées sur
son passage et aucune pollution sonore
un véhicule qui se fond dans le décor
côté logistique ce bus à hydrogène se
recharge en 10 minutes contre 4 à 6
heures pour un bus électrique beaucoup
de points positifs mais qui ont un prix
environ 800.000 euros l'unité c'est 4
fois plus qu'un bus thermique et deux
fois plus qu'un bus électrique on en a
deux comme ça sur cette on a que deux
buts à hydrogène mais tout le reste
c'est des électriques mais l'hydrogène
ne rime pas forcément avec écologie car
pour fabriquer cette source d'énergie et
l'acheminer il faut beaucoup de
ressources et d'énergie fossiles comme
le gaz naturel le pétrole ou le charbon
c'est juste derrière juste là derrière
merci à vous en 2022 seul 33 bus à
hydrogène circulaient sur l'ensemble du
territoire mais il devrait être près de
900 avant 2030 la course aux transports
durable est lancée le bus tente de faire
bouger les lignes et il n'est pas le
seul transport les ingénieurs fourmis
d'idées que ce soit dans les airs ou sur
terre c'est surtout assurer l'étanchéité
avec un avec le thé qui fait complet
puis émettre des boudins un petit peu
plus souples et si le transport de
demain c’était ses petites capsules des
véhicules à mi-chemin entre la voiture
autonome et le tramway
c'est une autre philosophie du transport
public c'est plus du transport en commun
on va mettre tout le monde dans la même
boîte où tous les sièges sont dans la
même boîte comme dans le métro le bus ou
ultramway ça c'est historique c'était du
temps on avait besoin de de mutualiser
ce qui coûtait cher le chauffeur et le
moteur thermique à partir du moment on a
plus de moteur thermique et on a plus de
chauffeur on peut éclater l'ensemble des
sièges dans un sablier plus le grain est
fin plus le débit est rapide dans le
transport c'est pareil si on va voir un
débit élevé des temps d'attente
restreints il faut fractionner le flux
en petits éléments et de faire en sorte
que ramener au coût du siège là ça coûte
pas plus cher que les transports lourds
des véhicules électriques sur des rails
qui se rendent à des destinations
différentes sans patienter les uns
derrière les autres
comme les gens ne vont pas tous au même
endroit les gens en fait ils mettent
simplement leur destination et ils vont
aller directement à destination ils vont
pas s'arrêter comme dans le métro où
tout le monde s'arrête à toutes les
stations dans le bus c'est pareil ils
vont directement à toutes les stations
pour rendre ça réalisable c'est de
mettre les stations donc en dérivation
du flux principal comme on a des
véhicules qui sont fins on peut doubler
la voix au niveau des stations d'un côté
ceux qui vont tout droit et de l'autre
côté ceux qui arrêtent comme ça c'est le
même principe que que l'autoroute ces
petites capsules peuvent transporter
jusqu'à 280 kg c'est l'équivalent d'une
famille de 4 personnes d'un voyageur et
son vélo ou d'une personne en fauteuil
roulant et son accompagnateur
et son point fort c'est sa consommation
équivalente à un appareil électroménager
il détient même le record du véhicule
autonome sur rail le moins énergivore au
monde on a vraiment choisi la sobriété
c'est extrêmement simple il n'y a pas de
matériaux compliqués il y a pas de
batterie il y a que les roues qui
tournent le faible courant électrique
circule dans les rails et capté par ses
petites balayettes qui alimentent les
moteurs intégrés aux roues une petite
commune qui n'a pas les moyens de se
payer un tramway va pouvoir se payer un
Urbano donc elle pourra déplacer moins
de monde qu'un tramway mais elle va
avoir une offre aujourd'hui qui est en
phase avec son besoin et ses capacités
financières qui sont aujourd'hui plus
restreintes que les grosses communes
évidemment pour les communes ce mode de
transport coûterait 25 fois moins cher
que le métro et 5 fois moins que le
tramway il pourrait permettre à 47
millions de Français d'effectuer leur
trajet quotidien et de laisser la
voiture au garage ces cap sules écolos
vont être installés à Paris le temps des
Jeux olympiques de 2024 et une première
ligne verra le jour à Nancy en 2026
[Musique]
alors on vient de le voir les
initiatives ne manquent pas pour rendre
le secteur des transports moins
polluants bonjour Thierry Mallet bonjour
merci d'être là avec nous vous êtes le
PDG de Transdev l'un des leader mondiaux
de la mobilité partagée du quotidien
avec près de 10 millions de passagers à
travers le monde il y a cette urgence
climatique qui vous oblige qui vous
engage et donc vous avez une stratégie
qui consiste comme beaucoup de boîtes à
réduire sensiblement vos émissions de
CO2 est-ce que déjà vous êtes alignés ou
pas encore parce que c'est pas facile
avec l'accord de Paris alors notre
objectif c'est d'être effectivement
aligné avec la coeur de Paris on a
l'objectif de réduire d'au moins 30% nos
émissions à l'horizon 2030 mais notre
objectif c'est pas simplement de réduire
les émissions et on le fait
effectivement en verdissant nos flottes
en passant à l'électrique en passant
l'hydrogène en passant en biogaz mais
aussi en offrant une alternative à la
voiture aujourd'hui plus de 80% de des
kilomètres quotidiens sont faits en
voiture et donc l'objectif c'est
effectivement de trouver une solution
différentes une solution partagée moins
polluante qui est mettre moins de CO2
pour permettre de se déplacer donc
quelle est la part justement Thierry
Maley de bus de train de bus surtout qui
roule encore au diesel en France donc on
mesure le chemin qui reste à parcourir
c'est probablement 80 % des bus sont
encore aujourd'hui au diesel en France
diesel ou biocarburant et ça prend
combien de temps pour renouveler encore
une fois les flottes après ça dépend des
collectivités bien sûr mais la durée de
vie d'un bus c'est 10 ans ça veut dire
que d'ici une dizaine d'années il y aura
effectivement uniquement débute
électrique dans les centres-villes mais
encore une fois on n'aura pas résolu la
question
alors pour l'instant on développe des
solutions avec des biocarburants avec
des carburants alternatifs le 95 on
développe des solutions avec
effectivement beaucoup moins de CO2
ah oui le biocarburant émet beaucoup
moins de CO2 il continue encore à
polluer mais si c'est vraiment un
biocarbure en renouvelable vous vous
réduisez très très fort
la plupart du temps c'est des gens qui
viennent de la périphérie qui n'ont pas
trouvé d'offres donc j'évoquais tout à
l'heure la solution qu'on a mis en place
entre crayon et Bordeaux avec à la fois
la région nouvelle-aquitaine et la
métropole
qui sont des cars qui permettent
effectivement de relier la périphérie au
centre et le soir le centre à la
périphérique qui sont des solutions
extrêmement efficaces qui marchent très
bien reportage il y a deux conditions
pour que ça marche la première c'est la
la qualité de service c'est à dire
effectivement pour travailler
tranquillement dans un carré Express ah
oui on peut travailler les filles et les
prises électriques c'est un trajet qui
est fait plus rapidement qu'en voiture
aujourd'hui puisque sur la liaison de
carexpress très souvent on peut avoir
une voix dédiée ou des aménagements au
niveau des carrefours des ronds qui vous
permettent de passer plus vite c'est la
garantie d'avoir un car toute la journée
c'est du 6 heures 22 heures et c'est des
cartes tous les quarts d'heure ou toutes
les 20 minutes en heure de pointe donc
ça vous permet d'être une vraie
alternative à la voiture vous posez pas
la question vous êtes sûr en avoir le
matin et un soir pour pouvoir rentrer
c'est pas trop d'arrêt c'est sur les 30
km de Créon Bordeaux il y a à peine 4
arrêts pour vous permettre effectivement
d'avoir un service de qualité le but
d'ailleurs c'est pas de venir vous
chercher devant chez vous vous continuez
d'utiliser votre voiture il y a un
parking relais mais au lieu de faire 30
ou 40 km en voiture vous en faites que
10 km en voiture exactement on fait un
bout du trajet en voiture après on la
laisse et puis on prend
le report modèle c'est abandonner sa
voiture au profit du transport public là
c'est du multimodal c'est à dire que la
voiture vous sert pour faire une partie
du trajet mais qu'une partie du trajet
et après vous pouvez prendre le car et
si votre trajet il fait 5 ou 10 km
demain c'est pas forcément une voiture
dont vous avez besoin vous pouvez
également le faire en vélo en
particulier en vélo électrique avec des
économies on y revient des économies à
la clé exactement l'urgence climatique
et puis aussi la lutte enfin pour aider
pouvoir d'achat des Français parce
qu'effectivement sur Créon Bordeaux
c'est 200 euros 200 euros d'économie par
mois pour les utilisateurs de cette
ligne là par rapport à leur animation
d'essence donc c'est quand même un gain
très très appréciable et ça résout aussi
le problème des adefe parce que ça vous
permet
des zones affaiblissement si vous n'avez
pas effectivement une voiture aux normes
qui vous permet pas d'aller en
centre-ville vous le centre-ville reste
encore accessible avec ce type de
solution et c'est un très bon complément
ferroviaire ce qu'on a entendu parler
effectivement des réseaux express
régionaux qui en réalité doivent être
des systèmes express régionaux dans
lequel vous aurez à la fois des trains
des cas Express parce que on ne pourra
pas avoir le train partout et le train
on sait que c'est une solution de long
terme qui va prendre 10 ans alors que
les cas Express ça peut se mettre en
place en 6 mois et roule à quoi
d'ailleurs ce carexpress alors dans le
cas de Bordeaux il roule à l'éthanol à
le 95 qui est du bioéthanol qui est fait
à partir de marc de raisin et il y a
d'autres implantations d'autres projets
d'implantation prévu alors de carexpress
alors la région nouvelle-aquitaine et la
Bordeaux ont prévu d'en faire d'autres
il y en a d'autres prévus également en
région
Île-de-France où il y a déjà également
quelques lignes de carexpress en
périphérie et il les autres métropoles
qui commencent à y réfléchir et il y a
un très très bel exemple et qui n'est
pas en France qui est le cas de Madrid
qui a tout un réseau de carexpress qui
transporte tous les jours plus de 500
000 personnes donc on n'a pas en retard
vous écoutez quand même en France on est
en retard on a juste l'opportunité
d'accélérer c'est la cliente là-dessus
le multimodal vous écoutez oui c'est
vraiment important demain la solution
c'est pas de supprimer la voiture dans
les espaces
demain imminent
puisque on voit très bien que le
multimodal grâce au digital vous permet
d'avoir une offre que vous comprenez
mieux parce que c'est une offre par
nature plus compliquée donc le digital
les calculateurs d'itinéraires vous
permettent de bien comprendre quel type
de trajet vous pouvez faire et de
l'organiser donc ça veut dire que
multimodal il est déjà là aujourd'hui
notamment périurbain exactement parce
que la voiture sera toujours partie de
la solution vous ne pouvez pas aller
dans l'équation la voiture elle restera
dans l'équation le but c'est de s'en
servir moins si on permet effectivement
aux gens traduit à leur consommation
de moitié ou des trois quarts grâce à
des solutions qui leur permettent
d'avoir un service de qualité on aura
fait un grand pas en avant on pourra
peut-être se passer dans la périphérie
de la deuxième voiture et ne garder plus
qu'une voiture c'est ça l'objectif allez
merci pour cet entretien Thierry Mallet
donc le PDG de transat merci à vous
merci alors maintenant s'intéresser à un
type de transport bien spécifique le
ramassage scolaire des solutions
existent pour le rendre moins polluant
[Musique]
et oui tous les enfants n'ont pas la
chance d'aller à l'école à pied parfois
ce sont les parents qui les déposent en
voiture parfois on a fret un bus pas
toujours rempli pour seulement quelques
kilomètres bonjour Émilie et ces trajets
ils sont redoutables pour
l'environnement alors c'est vrai
l'Observatoire de la qualité de l'air
d'Aix-en-Provence a d'ailleurs mesuré
l'impact à l'entrée et à la sortie des
écoles résultats c'est catastrophiques
en termes de pic de pollution et c'est
justement pour y remédier que la société
humburt basé à Nantes a conçu un bus
écolo et collaboratif le wdibus qui
d'ailleurs a commencé à faire ses
preuves à Louviers dans l'Eure pour les
enfants du CP au CM2
il est en bois ce qui lui donne un faux
air de machines à la Léonard de Vinci
en français n'est pas anodin car on va
le rappeler le bois c'est infiniment
moins polluant que l'alignement et tout
aussi performant et puis aussi cinq fois
plus léger c'est-à-dire pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il est utilisé dans
l'aéronautique chez les petits
constructeurs alors si j'ai bien compris
en regardant ces images le woodybus est
à mi-chemin entre un minibus et un vélo
électrique voilà il comprend 9 places
dont celle du chauffeur le chauffeur qui
le fait rouler grâce à une assistance
électrique qui a à peu près la même que
sur un vélo électrique elle-même est
alimentée par deux batteries qui se
rechargent via des panneaux solaires sur
le toit donc jusque-là rien de très
original sauf que avec le woodybus les
enfants sont mis à contribution en
pédalant comme sur n'importe quel vélo
sur sa selle chacun va à son rythme le
chauffeur lui à la main évidemment sur
sa conduite et sur le frein Émilie c'est
pas trop fatiguant pour nos bambins sur
tout le matin alors comme je vous disais
c'est le chauffeur qui fait avancer la
machine via l'assistance électrique les
enfants eux ils ont juste tapé d'aller
pour compenser leur poids et celui de
leur cartable un peu comme si finalement
ils allaient à l'école en vélo et
d'ailleurs c'est tout bénef car nous
Loupio bah du coup il pratique une
activité sportive dès le matin et les
maîtresses sont d'ailleurs formal elles
ont remarqué que les enfants étaient
nettement plus vif et plus éveillés en
arrivant à l'école sans doute grâce à
toute l'énergie dépensée sur le trajet
et qui est donc mieux canalisé dans la
salle de classe bon côté sécurité
maintenant est-ce que c'est
et Grenoble qui rappelons-le et la
capitale du vélo est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer d'autres applications tiens
pourquoi pas pour les adultes et ben
c'est peut-être sans doute la suite de
l'aventure car pas besoin d'une nouvelle
homologation pour pour les adultes en
fait il suffit juste de retirer deux
places donc une rangée pour que les
adultes aient l'espace suffisamment
d'espace pour mettre pour mettre leurs
jambes tout simplement un Bird est
d'ailleurs en discussion avec notamment
une station thermale et puis également
la commune de d'Argelès-sur-Mer pour des
déplacements du camping municipal
jusqu'à la plage donc vous le voyez
David il faudra peut-être désormais
s'habituer à pédaler à plusieurs pour
nous pour trajet en ville comme à la
campagne dans la bonne direction merci
Émilie merci voilà c'est la fin pourvu
que ça dure l'émission qui rend les
cours responsables les missions à voir
ou revoir sur Public Sénat ou en replay
sur public sana.fr on revient dans deux
semaines
[Musique]
pourvu que ça dure vous a été présenté
par écho DDS éco-organisme qui agit pour
une économie respectueuse de
l'environnement
[Musique]